Today's show is brought to you by T-Mobile for Business. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. We typically divide the United States into two political categories. Conservative, Democrats have blocked us at every turn. and Liberal. The Republicans are not serious. Finding common ground between these two groups,
今天的节目由 T-Mobile for Business 赞助播出。这里是 Hidden Brain，我是 Shankar Vedantan。我们通常将美国分为两个政治阵营：保守派——民主党人在每一个环节都阻挠我们；以及自由派——共和党人并不认真。在这两个群体之间寻找共同点，
Who is on your list? reaching across the aisle, has become increasingly rare. Because we keep trying to find a way to win without help from across the aisle. This is true not just in a metaphorical sense. In one study, researchers looked at more than 1,400 hours of tape on C-SPAN. The Senate will come to order the check. Hour after hour of hearings, committee mock-up sessions, testimony, resolutions.
谁在你的名单上？跨越党派界限已变得越来越罕见。因为我们一直在试图寻找一种无需对方帮助就能获胜的方法。这不仅是在隐喻意义上如此。在一项研究中，研究人员查看了超过 1400 小时的 C-SPAN 录像。参议院即将开会，请核对。一小时又一小时的听证会、委员会修改会议、证词、决议。
After all these hours watching C-SPAN, researchers concluded that since the 1990s, Democrats and Republicans in the U.S. Senate have physically crossed the aisle less and less to interact with opposing colleagues. That means senators are staying with their like-minded colleagues, not just in the legislation they are trying to pass, but also by literally steering clear of the carpeted pathway that splits the Senate floor. Today we continue our us 2.0 series by taking a few steps back and looking at the challenge of political division through a new lens. We hope we will provide a new way to understand the people sitting across from us at the dinner table. People don't seem to dislike somebody just for being a member of the other side.
在观看了这么多小时的 C-SPAN 后，研究人员得出结论：自 20 世纪 90 年代以来，美国参议院的民主党人和共和党人为了与对方同事互动而跨越党派界限的次数越来越少。这意味着参议员们不仅在试图通过的立法上与志同道合的同事待在一起，而且在字面意义上也避开了分割参议院大厅的铺设地毯的通道。今天，我们通过退后几步，以全新的视角审视政治分歧带来的挑战，继续我们的“我们 2.0”系列节目。我们希望这能提供一种新的方式来理解坐在餐桌对面的人。人们似乎并不只是因为对方是另一阵营的成员而讨厌某人。
They're concerned that somebody is going to talk to them about politics. And if somebody is going to talk to you about politics, of course you'd rather talk to somebody of your own side. This week on Hidden Brain, why the division you hear about all the time in our politics might not be what really divides us. Yana Krupnikov is a political scientist at the University of Michigan. She studies a subject we hear about a lot, the bitter political divide in the United States. But Yana has a counterintuitive thesis.
他们担心的是对方会和他们谈论政治。如果有人要和你谈论政治，你当然更愿意和自己阵营的人谈。本周的 Hidden Brain 将探讨为什么你在政治中一直听到的分歧可能并不是真正分裂我们的原因。Yana Krupnikov 是一位密歇根大学的政治学家。她研究的是我们经常听到的一个话题：美国激烈的政治分歧。但 Yana 有一个反直觉的论点。
She thinks the real fault line in America is actually not between Republicans and Democrats. Yana Krupnikov, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. I want to play your clip, Yana, from a CNN program titled, Welcome to the Fractured States of America. The number of parents who would be unhappy if their child married someone of a different political party, that number has exploded over the last several decades, from 4% in 1960 to 35% of Republicans and 45% of Democrats in 2018.
她认为美国真正的分歧线实际上并不在共和党和民主党之间。Yana Krupnikov，欢迎来到 Hidden Brain。谢谢你邀请我。Yana，我想播放你的一段剪辑，来自 CNN 一档名为《欢迎来到分裂的美国》的节目。如果孩子与不同政党的人结婚，父母会感到不高兴的人数在过去几十年里激增，从 1960 年的 4% 增加到 2018 年共和党人的 35% 和民主党人的 45%。
Yana, you have a critique of this notion of a fractured country, but I want you to start by laying out the conventional wisdom first. What are we all told about the state of political polarization in the United States? A lot of what we're told about the state of political polarization in the United States? A lot of what we're told about the state of political polarization is that polarization has increased quite vastly over potentially the last decade. What's interesting about this polarization is that there's a two-fold approach here. So on the one hand, polarization can be ideological, but on the other hand, it can be affective. And affective polarization is the sense of disliking somebody just because they're a member of the other party, without their issues, without kind of their positions, just because they belong to this opposing group.
Yana，你对这个“分裂国家”的概念有批评意见，但我希望你先从阐述传统观点开始。关于美国政治极化的现状，我们都被告知了什么？关于政治极化现状的很多说法是，极化在过去十年左右的时间里急剧增加。这种极化有趣的地方在于它有两种路径。一方面，极化可以是意识形态上的；但另一方面，它可以是情感上的。而情感极化是指仅仅因为某人是对方政党的成员就讨厌他，不考虑他们的议题，不考虑他们的立场，仅仅因为他们属于这个对立群体。
So when we talk about Democrats not wanting their child to marry a Republican, or Republicans not wanting their child to marry a Democrat, we're talking often about this idea of affect. Just the sense of dislike, this antipathy for the other side, and there's this tremendous kind of pattern showing increases in this level of antipathy. That people who are from one party just dislike the other party much more than they did in years past. And some of this is almost to an extreme. I mean some some people have even asked whether ordinary Americans see their political
所以当我们谈论民主党人不希望他们的孩子嫁给共和党人，或者共和党人不希望他们的孩子嫁给民主党人时，我们通常谈论的是这种情感观念。仅仅是一种厌恶感，对另一方的反感，而且有一种巨大的模式显示这种反感程度在增加。来自一个政党的人比过去几年更讨厌另一个政党。其中一些甚至到了极端的程度。我的意思是，有些人甚至问过普通美国人是否将他们的政治
opponents as even fully human. Indeed there's actually a lot of examples of this antipathy. There's research suggesting that people wouldn't want somebody to, as I just said, marry somebody from the other party, that they wouldn't want to hire somebody from the opposing party, that they don't see the other party as human, that they might actually want to do something that would make life for somebody from the opposing party much worse. So there are a lot of these almost non-political examples of places where partisanship and dislike for the other side has quite profoundly affected the way we see the world and the
对手视为完整的人。事实上，确实有很多这种反感的例子。有研究表明，人们不希望某人——正如我刚才所说——与对方政党的人结婚，他们不希望雇佣对方政党的人，他们不认为对方政党的人是人，他们甚至可能想做一些让对方政党的人生活变得更糟的事情。所以有很多这种几乎非政治的例子，党派偏见和对另一方的厌恶已经深刻地影响了我们看待世界的方式和
way we see other people. So we're told Americans don't want to live next to one another, political partisans that is, they can't bear to talk to one another and of course they don't want their children marrying people from the other party. You conducted a survey some years ago when you drill down specifically on the marriage question. What was the hunch you were exploring and what did you ask? So the way we looked at the marriage question happened during these conversations I'd had with my co-authors John Barry Ryan and Samara Clark.
我们看待他人的方式。所以我们被告知美国人不想住在一起，我是指政治党派人士，他们无法忍受彼此交谈，当然他们也不希望自己的孩子与对方政党的人结婚。你几年前进行了一项调查，专门深入研究了婚姻问题。你当时在探索什么直觉，你问了什么？我们看待婚姻问题的方式源于我与合著者 John Barry Ryan 和 Samara Clark 的对话。
And so we were talking about this marriage question that something about it seemed quite unusual to us. You are in a survey, you're being asked whether you want your child to marry somebody from the other party, but that's really all you know about this person. All you know about them is that they are a Republican or that they are a Democrat. And when that's all you know about them, one, you can't really put that person into context. But the other thing you might think about them is essentially, if they're telling me this person's partisanship, that person's partisanship is probably something that's
当时我们正在讨论这个婚姻问题，它似乎有些不同寻常。你在调查中被问到是否希望你的孩子与对方政党的人结婚，但关于这个人你只知道这些。你只知道他们是共和党人或民主党人。当你只知道这些时，第一，你无法真正将那个人置于背景中。但你可能想到的另一件事本质上是，如果他们告诉我这个人的党派倾向，那么那个人的党派倾向可能对他们来说是
really, really important to them. So if I was inviting you to meet one of my friends and we had just a brief moment and I used that brief moment to tell you, you're gonna meet my friend, she likes cats. You might imagine that you're about to meet somebody who is essentially gonna talk nonstop about cats if that's the only thing I shared with you about this person.
非常、非常重要的。所以如果我邀请你去见我的一个朋友，我们只有短暂的时间，我利用那短暂的时间告诉你，你要见我的朋友，她喜欢猫。如果这是我关于这个人分享的唯一信息，你可能会想象你即将见到一个基本上会不停地谈论猫的人。
And so what if this is what's happening in a survey? What if when people are asked about this hypothetical in-law and the only thing they know about this person is that they're a member of the opposing party, what if they're imagining somebody who will literally talk about politics for every dinner from now on as their in-law? And what did you find
那么如果这就是调查中发生的情况呢？如果当人们被问及这个假设的姻亲时，他们对这个人唯一的了解就是他们是对方政党的成员，如果他们想象的是一个从今以后每一顿饭都会字面意义上谈论政治的姻亲呢？当你真正问美国人这个问题时，你发现了什么？
when you actually asked Americans this question? How did you tweaklaw. And what did you find when you actually asked Americans this question? How did you tweak the question and what did you find? So what we ended up doing is we amended the question a bit. We basically added a qualification. We told people that this future in-law, this hypothetical in-law, was actually never really going to talk about politics. They might be from the other parties, but they were never actually going to discuss anything political. And so we ran an experiment in which people were randomly assigned to either a group
当你真正问美国人这个问题时，你发现了什么？你是如何调整问题的，你发现了什么？我们最终做的是稍微修改了这个问题。我们基本上增加了一个限定条件。我们告诉人们，这个未来的姻亲，这个假设的姻亲，实际上从来不会真正谈论政治。他们可能来自对方政党，但他们实际上永远不会讨论任何政治话题。于是我们进行了一项实验，人们被随机分配到一组
in which they got asked the normal question, how happy would you be if your child married somebody from the opposing party, versus a question in which they were told, how happy would you be if your child married somebody from the opposing party, versus a question in which they were told how happy would you be if your child married somebody from an opposing party, but this person was never going to talk about politics. And what we found is significant differences in people's preferences for the other side. Once people were told that their child's future spouse was actually not really going to talk about politics, their animosity toward the other side quite profoundly decreased. In other words, if I was a Republican parent, the thing that
他们被问到正常的问题：如果你的孩子与对方政党的人结婚，你会多高兴？或者被问到另一个问题：如果你的孩子与对方政党的人结婚，但这个人永远不会谈论政治，你会多高兴？我们发现人们对另一方的偏好存在显著差异。一旦人们被告知他们孩子未来的配偶实际上不会真正谈论政治，他们对另一方的敌意就大大降低了。换句话说，如果我是一位共和党父母，我最担心的可能不是
I might be most worried about is not that my child is going to marry a Democrat, my child's going to marry a Democrat who's going to talk politics all the time. If I had the reassurance that politics was not going to come up all the time, my feelings about my future Democratic son-in-law or daughter-in-law changed quite profoundly. Exactly. In theory, what people were concerned about is essentially politics coming up in their day-to-day lives. They actually were not as concerned about the opposing partisanship component of it.
我的孩子要嫁给一个民主党人，而是我的孩子要嫁给一个会一直谈论政治的民主党人。如果我得到保证说政治不会一直被提起，我对未来民主党女婿或儿媳的感受就会发生深刻的变化。没错。从理论上讲，人们担心的是政治出现在他们的日常生活中。他们实际上并不那么担心对方的党派成分。
To better understand how this played out in people's lives, Yana and her colleagues ran the study again, but changed whether the hypothetical new daughter or son-in-law talked about politics frequently, occasionally, or rarely. They found that what people cared about the most was not whether a future son-in-law or daughter-in-law had different politics, but how much the future in-law wanted to talk about politics. People don't seem to dislike somebody just for being a member of the other side. They're concerned that somebody is going to talk to them about politics and if somebody is going to talk to you about politics of course you'd
为了更好地理解这在人们生活中是如何体现的，Yana 和她的同事再次进行了这项研究，但改变了假设的新儿媳或女婿谈论政治的频率：频繁、偶尔或很少。他们发现人们最关心的不是未来的女婿或儿媳是否有不同的政治立场，而是未来的姻亲有多想谈论政治。人们似乎并不只是因为对方是另一阵营的成员而讨厌某人。他们担心的是对方会和他们谈论政治，如果有人要和你谈论政治，你当然
rather talk to somebody of your own side. If that's going to be part of your life at every dinner certainly of course you wouldn't want it to be contentious. But the key aspect there is conversations, not necessarily partisanship. So I'm thinking of a clip from Saturday Night Live that I think your research speaks to. It's actually about a wedding celebration and the celebration is interrupted by the character known as Debbie Downer. Yeah, these mashed potatoes look like heaven. After we eat, I vote we get a line dance ball. Oh, yeah. Hey, speaking of voting, how do you guys feel about Trump?
更愿意和自己阵营的人谈。如果这会成为你每一顿晚餐生活的一部分，你当然不希望它是充满争议的。但其中的关键点是对话，而不一定是党派偏见。我想到了《周六夜现场》中的一个片段，我认为你的研究可以解释它。它实际上是关于一场婚礼庆典，庆典被一个叫 Debbie Downer 的角色打断了。是的，这些土豆泥看起来像天堂一样。吃完后，我提议我们跳排舞。哦，对了。嘿，说到投票，你们觉得特朗普怎么样？
What do you think, Yana? Do you think that clip speaks to your thesis? I think it speaks to the thesis quite profoundly. I think, actually, that is exactly what people are quite worried about. You're having kind of a nice celebration. Somebody comes in for whom politics is incredibly important, who is essentially going to change the conversation to that particular bent. So imagine that every dinner you're now
你觉得呢，Yana？你认为那个片段能说明你的论点吗？我认为它非常深刻地说明了这一论点。实际上，我认为这正是人们非常担心的。你正在进行一场愉快的庆祝活动。有人进来了，对他们来说政治极其重要，他们基本上会把谈话转向那个特定的方向。所以想象一下，每一顿晚餐你现在都
incredibly tense, trying to figure out is there something political that's going to happen here? I think that's what people are deeply concerned about. Imagine sitting at dinner with friends and family. Someone mentions a tweet from Trump. Everyone freezes. Will this become an argument? Yana's data suggests that if the people around your table were a cross-section of America, most would prefer to change the topic. But some people would get super excited. It's these people who would also be really upset if a child of theirs were to marry someone from the other party.
极其紧张，试图弄清楚这里会不会发生什么政治事件？我认为这正是人们深感担忧的地方。想象一下和朋友家人坐在一起吃晚餐。有人提到了特朗普的一条推文。每个人都僵住了。这会变成一场争论吗？Yana 的数据表明，如果餐桌周围的人是美国社会的缩影，大多数人会更愿意转换话题。但有些人会变得非常兴奋。正是这些人，如果他们的孩子要与对方政党的人结婚，他们也会非常不安。
from the other party. There certainly is a group of people who are in fact effectively polarized. No matter how we describe this in-law, they are displeased with their child marrying somebody of the opposing side. I would bet that even if we told them politics will literally never come up ever ever ever They would still be displeased that their child married somebody of the opposing party these people struck us as being what we would term unconditionally polarized they were sort of Polarized exactly in the sense of Hating somebody just because they are from the other side.
从对方政党。确实有一群人实际上是情感极化的。无论我们如何描述这个姻亲，他们都不高兴自己的孩子与对方阵营的人结婚。我敢打赌，即使我们告诉他们政治真的永远、永远、永远不会被提起，他们仍然会因为孩子与对方阵营的人结婚而不高兴。这些人让我们觉得他们就是我们所说的“无条件极化者”，他们是那种
And as we dove into this question further, we wanted to investigate exactly what contributes to this unconditional polarization, what correlates with somebody disliking somebody just from being a member of the other side, which led us to this idea of certain people being deeply involved in politics, people for whom politics has become so profoundly important that it's something beyond just an interest in politics. So as you say, the deeply involved care a lot about politics, like Debbie Downer, they want to talk about politics even to people who want to talk about something else. But you make a remarkable claim.
极化，正是那种仅仅因为对方来自另一阵营就讨厌某人的意义上的极化。当我们进一步深入研究这个问题时，我们想调查到底是什么导致了这种无条件极化，什么与某人仅仅因为对方是另一阵营的成员就讨厌某人相关，这引导我们得出了某些人深度参与政治的想法，对这些人来说，政治已经变得如此重要，以至于不仅仅是对政治的兴趣。正如你所说，深度参与者非常关心政治，就像 Debbie Downer 一样，他们甚至想对那些想谈论其他事情的人谈论政治。但你提出了一个非凡的观点。
You say the central fault line today in the United States might not be between Republicans and Democrats, but between people who are deeply involved in politics and everybody else. What do you mean by that? When we think about deep involvement, we think of somebody for whom politics is front and center. It is something that they think about on a daily basis.
你说今天美国真正的分歧线可能不在共和党和民主党之间，而是在深度参与政治的人和所有人之间。你是什么意思？当我们想到深度参与时，我们想到的是那些将政治视为核心的人。这是他们每天都会思考的事情。
It's something that they think about actually probably on an hourly basis. It is something that is a center to the way that they view the world. And so John Ryan and I, in describing these people and thinking about these people, conceive of them as being quite different from actually the majority of Americans and the majority of people. We see the fault line is how central you view politics through the world, how much attention you pay to politics, how you interpret political events,
这实际上可能是他们每小时都会思考的事情。这是他们看待世界方式的核心。所以 John Ryan 和我在描述这些人并思考这些人时，认为他们实际上与大多数美国人和大多数人非常不同。我们认为分歧线在于你将政治视为看待世界的核心程度，你对政治的关注程度，你如何解读政治事件，
how much of an impact you believe that politics has in your life. And we see it as a fault line in the sense that for people who are deeply involved, politics is of such profound importance that it dominates the world perspective, it dominates how they view others, it dominates what they do with their day. And we see that as being profoundly different from a large group of Americans for whom politics is less important and for whom politics seems more as something that is happening on the side,
你认为政治对你的生活有多大影响。我们认为这是一种分歧线，因为对于深度参与的人来说，政治具有如此深远的重要性，以至于它主导了世界观，主导了他们看待他人的方式，主导了他们一天所做的事情。我们认为这与一大群美国人截然不同，对他们来说政治不那么重要，政治看起来更像是发生在旁边的事情，
something that is potentially troubling, something that is potentially problematic, but something that they don't necessarily want to think about all that much. I want to spend some time talking about the characteristics of the people you describe as deeply involved, because of course it's one thing to say this is a distinct group, but you go further than that. Through a series of surveys and experiments involving thousands of Americans, you find the deeply involved have a set
可能是令人不安的事情，可能是潜在的问题，但他们不一定想太多。我想花点时间谈谈你所描述的“深度参与者”的特征，因为说这是一个独特的群体是一回事，但你走得更远。通过一系列涉及数千名美国人的调查和实验，你发现深度参与者有一套
of very distinct characteristics. And the first identifier is something that you hinted at a second ago. These are people who spend a lot of time on politics. Yes. When we think about the deeply involved, we think about a set of psychological characteristics that lead somebody to sort of really care about politics, to think about it a ton. In fact,
非常独特的特征。第一个识别标志是你刚才提到的。这些人花大量时间在政治上。是的。当我们想到深度参与者时，我们想到的是一系列心理特征，这些特征导致某人真正关心政治，思考它很多。事实上，
for a research, we began with the psychology of people who are our fans of things. And one of the things that emerges when you think about something being important to you is time. Why would you spend time on something that's not important to you? Obviously. What makes this a particularly unique moment for these people is now you actually can spend a tremendous amount of time on politics. You can basically wake up, you can unlock your phone, you can immediately start scrolling through the news, and you can basically be connected to politics for your entire day.
对于研究来说，我们从人们成为某事物的粉丝的心理开始。当你认为某事对你很重要时，会出现的一件事就是时间。你为什么要花时间在对你不重要的事情上？显然。让这些人处于一个特别独特的时刻的是，现在你确实可以花大量时间在政治上。你基本上可以醒来，解锁手机，立即开始滚动浏览新闻，你基本上可以整天与政治保持联系。
Another trait of the deeply involved on both sides of the political spectrum is that they're interested in minor political developments. They see deep significance in events that may or may not be important. Think back to 2017, for example, when former President Donald Trump posted the single word Kofef, or Kofefi, or Kofif, C-O-V-F-E-F-E, on Twitter, the social media site now known as X. The Kofefi tweet that Mercurial late night presidential sentence fragment with one of the best words stayed up with no explanation for hours and hours and hours, and then as dawn broke, the president suddenly deleted it and wrote, quote, who can figure out the true meaning of Koffefe? Yana, I remember watching the story
深度参与者在政治光谱两端的另一个特征是他们对微小的政治发展感兴趣。他们认为可能重要也可能不重要的事件具有深远的意义。回想一下 2017 年，当时前总统唐纳德·特朗普在推特（现在的 X）上发布了一个单词“Kofef”或“Kofefi”或“Kofif”，C-O-V-F-E-F-E。那条“Kofefi”推文，那个反复无常的深夜总统句子片段，带着最好的词之一，在没有任何解释的情况下挂了几个小时又几个小时，然后黎明破晓时，总统突然删除了它并写道，引用：“谁能弄明白 Koffefe 的真正含义？”Yana，我记得看这个故事
and getting a laugh out of it, but I also remember people going on about how the tweet might reflect a neurodegenerative disorder in the president. They took this really, really seriously. And I think that is sort of profound. The Koffefe tweet is in some sense, I think a profound example of deep involvement.
并从中笑出声来，但我也记得人们一直在谈论这条推文可能反映了总统的神经退行性疾病。他们非常、非常认真地对待这件事。我认为这在某种程度上是深刻的。我认为“Kofefi”推文在某种意义上是深度参与的一个深刻例子。
This thing happens, this thing that is ostensibly ridiculous, right? It's obviously a typo. But it becomes something that is of import to people. There are people who are anxious that they missed this tweet. There are people wondering what this tweet means, and as people think about it more, especially people who are deeply engaged in politics, they start to make more and more connections to political events. Is it something meaningful? Is it something about the president? What's going to happen next? And the reality about politics is that a lot of what happens in politics is in fact a matter of life and death.
这件事发生了，这件事表面上是荒谬的，对吧？这显然是一个拼写错误。但它变成了对人们来说很重要的事情。有些人担心他们错过了这条推文。有些人想知道这条推文意味着什么，随着人们思考得越多，尤其是那些深度参与政治的人，他们开始与政治事件建立越来越多的联系。它有意义吗？它与总统有关吗？接下来会发生什么？关于政治的现实是，政治中发生的很多事情实际上确实是生死攸关的问题。
But for the deeply involved, even typo tweets can become something that is actually very, very, very important. And that sort of makes sense. If you spend so much time with politics, if you spend so much time with politics, if you spend so much time following it, you know enough where almost everything can be of profound importance, where the president making a typo
但对于深度参与者来说，即使是拼写错误的推文也可能变成实际上非常、非常、非常重要的事情。这在某种程度上是有道理的。如果你花这么多时间在政治上，如果你花这么多时间关注它，你就会知道足够多，几乎所有事情都可能具有深远的重要性，总统犯了一个拼写错误
could be a signal of kind of what's to come, something about the political state of the world. So for the deeply involved, the engagement with politics kind of contributes to the perception that any next event could be the event that kind of changes everything. In other words, the deeply involved follow politics in the same way that some people follow our favorite sports team, or the twists and turns in a beloved TV show. Yana draws an analogy between people who are deeply involved in politics and fans of the
可能是一个信号，预示着未来会发生什么，关于世界政治状态的事情。所以对于深度参与者来说，对政治的参与在某种程度上促成了这样一种看法：任何下一个事件都可能是改变一切的事件。换句话说，深度参与者关注政治的方式，就像有些人关注我们最喜欢的运动队，或者心爱的电视剧中的曲折情节一样。Yana 在深度参与政治的人和科幻剧《神秘博士》的粉丝之间进行了类比。
sci-fi show Doctor Who. Multiple actors have portrayed the Doctor in the television show. And for years, fans have argued obsessively about which actor is the best Doctor. With the exception of the very bottom slot, which we'll get to in a second, I don't think there is a bad version of the doctor. What's the connection between Doctor Who, Eficionados, and Politics, Yana? So Doctor Who, I think, is a really interesting kind of example, because in some sense, to have a favorite Doctor Who, you have to be a fan of the show.
多位演员在电视剧中扮演过博士。多年来，粉丝们一直痴迷地争论哪位演员是最好的博士。除了最底层的那个位置，我们稍后会谈到，我不认为有糟糕的博士版本。Yana，神秘博士爱好者和政治之间有什么联系？所以神秘博士，我认为是一个非常有趣的例子，因为在某种意义上，要有一个最喜欢的神秘博士，你必须是该剧的粉丝。
Because one of the beautiful things about Doctor Who is everyone gets to have their doctor. Your pick does not have to be anyone else's. You do not have to rank them the way anyone else does. Somebody who does not have a favorite Doctor Who is probably not a huge fan of the show, or maybe a more peripheral fan of the show. And so what your criticism is,
因为神秘博士的美妙之处在于每个人都可以有自己的博士。你的选择不必是别人的选择。你不必像其他人那样对他们进行排名。没有最喜欢的神秘博士的人可能不是该剧的超级粉丝，或者可能是一个边缘粉丝。所以你的批评是，
when you criticize somebody's favorite doctor pick is that they are involved, but they are involved in the wrong way. So starting at the bottom, Colin Baker. When we read research on this sort of support for the doctor, the psychology seemed almost similar to politics, of course, with much lower stakes. But there's the sense that somebody could be on your political side, but they could be on your political side in not exactly the right way. And there is going
当你批评某人最喜欢的博士选择时，他们是参与其中的，但他们参与的方式不对。所以从底部开始，Colin Baker。当我们阅读关于这种对博士的支持的研究时，心理似乎与政治几乎相似，当然，赌注要低得多。但有一种感觉，某人可能在你的政治阵营，但他们可能以不完全正确的方式在你的政治阵营。而且会有
to be something frustrating to somebody who is deeply involved, that this person is coming so close to getting it, but is actually not there. There's another connection between Doctor Who fans and political fanatics. Neither can stop talking about their obsession. When we come back, how journalists favor the zealous voices of the deeply involved. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantan. Political scientist Yana Kriplnikov argues that most Americans are not seeing the defining political fault line in the country. It's not Republican versus Democrat, but the gap between people who live, breathe, and talk politics all the time,
一些让深度参与者感到沮丧的事情，这个人快要搞懂了，但实际上并没有达到那个程度。神秘博士粉丝和政治狂热者之间还有另一个联系。两者都无法停止谈论他们的痴迷。回来后，记者如何偏袒深度参与者的狂热声音。你正在收听 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedant。这里是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantan。政治学家 Yana Kriplnikov 认为，大多数美国人并没有看到该国决定性的政治分歧线。这不是共和党对民主党，而是那些生活、呼吸、整天谈论政治的人，
and those for whom politics is a small part of their lives. The deeply involved spend lots of time learning about politics, thinking about politics. But they also do one other thing that the less engaged rarely do. Yana, you say the most defining feature of the people who are deeply involved in politics is something you call expression. What do you mean by that? When we think about expression, we mean the desire to communicate politics. We mean the desire to not just speak about information
与那些政治只是他们生活一小部分的人之间的差距。深度参与者花大量时间了解政治、思考政治。但他们还做了一件不太投入的人很少做的事情。Yana，你说深度参与政治的人最显著的特征是你所说的“表达”。你是什么意思？当我们想到表达时，我们指的是沟通政治的愿望。我们指的是不仅谈论信息
or speak about ways that you might change politics, but really expressing your own beliefs and feelings about politics. So really speaking your mind in the sense of something happens and you immediately want to tell others how you felt about it, whether it was good, how it made you think. But it's the idea of essentially expressing your views, expressing what others should
或谈论你可能改变政治的方式，而是真正表达你自己对政治的信仰和感受。所以真正说出你的想法，意思是某事发生了，你立即想告诉别人你的感受，无论是好是坏，它让你怎么想。但这本质上是表达你的观点，表达别人应该
do, just literally talking about what politics means to you. Now social media, you argue, is an important part of the story. How so? Well, in the past, if I wanted to talk to somebody about politics, I would have to find a person to literally talk about politics too. And maybe I couldn't find somebody to talk about politics to that day, and so I just wouldn't get to talk about it. Or maybe I found a friend and I just told him all about my political feelings
做什么，仅仅是字面意义上谈论政治对你意味着什么。现在，你认为社交媒体是这个故事的重要组成部分。怎么说呢？好吧，过去，如果我想和某人谈论政治，我必须找到一个人来字面意义上谈论政治。也许那天我找不到人谈论政治，所以我只是没能谈论它。或者也许我找到了一个朋友，我只是告诉他我所有的政治感受
and they just didn't really care. But now, if I can go to Twitter and I can type a political opinion... I just changed the channel from the Trump Town Hall to the Biden Town Hall and immediately fell asleep. There is a high probability that a number of people will chime in. Oh my God, it was so boring. We need to support Trump 100%. And potentially a lot of them might tell me that I'm right.
而他们并不真正关心。但现在，如果我可以去推特，我可以输入一个政治观点……我刚把频道从特朗普的市政厅会议换到了拜登的市政厅会议，然后立刻睡着了。很有可能很多人会插话。天哪，太无聊了。我们需要 100% 支持特朗普。而且可能很多人会告诉我我是对的。
It was like listening to grandpa after he... Tapes Biden's town hall to help me fall asleep. And certainly because it's Twitter, it's possible that a bunch of people will also chime in and tell me that I am a terrible person. I'm pretty sure America could do with a good night's sleep. I test my ballot for Joe Biden. It's the role of government to entertain its people or to protect them.
就像听爷爷在……录下拜登的市政厅会议来帮我入睡。当然，因为是推特，也可能有一群人会插话并告诉我我是一个糟糕的人。我很确定美国可以睡个好觉。我为乔·拜登投了票。政府的职责是娱乐人民还是保护他们。
But at least there will be somebody who allows me that expression. You have a story about social media from your own life that isn't about politics, but it says so much about how many of us, I think, engage with politics. Can you tell me the story of your toddler and the plane trip? Yes. So my daughter and I were on a flight, and my husband was there as well. My daughter was about one and a half at the time. It was a seven hour flight.
但至少会有人允许我进行这种表达。你有一个关于社交媒体的故事，来自你自己的生活，不是关于政治的，但它说明了我们很多人我认为是如何参与政治的。你能讲讲你蹒跚学步的孩子和飞机旅行的故事吗？是的。我和我女儿在飞机上，我丈夫也在那里。我女儿当时大约一岁半。那是一次七小时的飞行。
My daughter was basically being herself. She was being a one and a half year old. And into this flight, I started noticing this woman ahead of us would constantly just turn every time my daughter would make a slight noise. And this frustrated me. This made me quite upset. And it's this feeling of am I doing a terrible job? Am I a terrible parent? Why does this woman keep turning around? Is my kid being this bad? And so I did the first thing that came to my mind. I paid for internet so I could go to Twitter. And I tweeted about the fact that I'm on this flight and this woman keeps turning around and just looking at my
我女儿基本上是在做她自己。她是一个一岁半的孩子。在这次飞行中，我开始注意到前面的那个女人每当我女儿发出轻微的声音时，就会不断地回头。这让我很沮丧。这让我很不高兴。这是一种感觉：我做得太糟糕了吗？我是一个糟糕的父母吗？为什么这个女人一直回头？我的孩子真的那么糟糕吗？所以我做了我脑海中想到的第一件事。我付钱买了互联网，这样我就可以上推特。我发推文说我在这次飞行中，这个女人一直回头看着我的
daughter. And the thing is, I want to emphasize here that it was pretty safe for me to tweet that, right? I knew pretty much what my network was like. Immediately the replies kept pouring in, telling me that it was definitely not me, that it was definitely her. In fact, I think it was one of the most engaged tweets, right? I don't get that much engagement when I tweet about my research. And in that moment, so two things happened. So first, I felt really good. It was actually very good to have this social support from a bunch of internet people. The second thing is that it made me just much anger at this woman because it was this kind of feeling of all these people on the internet think that you're a wrong
女儿。重点是，我想在这里强调，发那条推文对我来说相当安全，对吧？我非常清楚我的网络是什么样的。回复立即涌入，告诉我绝对不是我的问题，绝对是她的问题。事实上，我认为这是我发过的互动最多的推文之一，对吧？当我发关于我的研究的推文时，我没有得到那么多互动。在那一刻，发生了两件事。首先，我感觉很好。从一群互联网人那里得到这种社会支持实际上非常好。第二件事是，这让我对这个女人更加愤怒，因为这是一种感觉：互联网上的所有这些人认为你是那个错误的
airplane lady and they're telling me that I am right. Eventually, the seven-hour flight was over. The plane landed, and Jana's husband took his phone off airplane mode and went online, where he saw his wife's post and all the responses. And he was actually really surprised. He did not notice the woman, even though she was actually more in his eyesight than mine. He did not see her turning around at any point.
飞机女士，他们告诉我我是对的。最终，七小时的飞行结束了。飞机降落了，Jana 的丈夫把手机关掉了飞行模式并上网，在那里他看到了妻子的帖子和所有的回复。他实际上非常惊讶。他没有注意到那个女人，尽管她实际上比我更在他的视线范围内。他没有看到她在任何时候回头。
He thought everything had gone really well. And it was a sort of a notable moment. I had had this moment, and yet here was somebody sitting next to me who had no idea what I was talking about. He didn't notice anything at all. And I can see the really wonderful metaphor here with the way our politics unfolds on social media and the way we so many of us engage with politics on social media. But there's also something of a mystery here. You say that
他认为一切都很顺利。这是一个值得注意的时刻。我经历了那个时刻，然而坐在我旁边的人却不知道我在说什么。他根本没有注意到任何事情。我可以看到这与我们的政治在社交媒体上展开的方式以及我们许多人参与社交媒体政治的方式之间有着非常美妙的隐喻。但这里也有一个谜。你说
the people who are deeply involved are a minority of all Americans. So why is it, Jana, that we feel like we hear their voices all the time? We hear the deeply involved because they're actually very loud. And I don't mean that they're necessarily screaming, but I mean that in the sense that they are more likely to occupy our social media feeds. Their voices are more likely to be talking about politics. So it seems like they're everywhere because whenever we encounter politics, it is quite often the voices of these people who are very, very deeply involved. And so if you're constantly seeing these posts about politics, you might not realize that they are from a very small set of people, or you might think to yourself, well, I guess
深度参与者只是所有美国人中的少数。那么，Jana，为什么我们觉得我们一直听到他们的声音呢？我们听到深度参与者的声音是因为他们实际上非常大声。我并不是说他们一定在尖叫，我的意思是他们更有可能占据我们的社交媒体信息流。他们的声音更有可能谈论政治。所以看起来他们无处不在，因为每当我们遇到政治时，往往就是这些深度参与的人的声音。所以如果你不断看到这些关于政治的帖子，你可能没有意识到它们来自一小部分人，或者你可能会想，好吧，我想
I'm the odd person out. I never talk about politics, but I guess everyone else is. And so you kind of come to this idea that the politically involved are much more around us than they actually are in numbers. Yana, you also make the case that one reason we hear the voices of the deeply involved everywhere is because journalists have a deep affinity for the voices of the deeply involved. Why is this? If we think about what media coverage includes, it's a lot of conflict and the deeply involved are kind of readily there to provide the conflict. They're going to be the people who can be most critical of the other side. They're going to the people who are gonna talk most passionately about politics.
我是那个异类。我从不谈论政治，但我想其他人都在谈论。所以你就会产生一种想法，即政治参与者在我们周围比实际人数要多得多。Yana，你还认为我们到处都能听到深度参与者的声音的一个原因是记者对深度参与者的声音有深厚的亲和力。为什么会这样？如果我们考虑媒体报道包括什么，那就是大量的冲突，而深度参与者很容易提供这种冲突。他们将是那些最能批评对方的人。他们将是那些最热情地谈论政治的人。
And so it sort of follows that journalists are gonna be heavily drawn to people who are deeply involved. And so part and parcel of this coverage is actually coverage of political polarization. If journalists are drawn to coverage of political polarization, then they are almost, by definition, going to be drawn to the voices of the deeply involved.
所以记者会被深度参与的人所吸引也就不足为奇了。这种报道的一部分实际上就是对政治极化的报道。如果记者被政治极化的报道所吸引，那么他们几乎在定义上就会被深度参与者的声音所吸引。
And so they come to dominate these stories as examples of just how terrible partisan relations are. Yana has run studies with hundreds of journalists across the United States. She has asked them the marriage question we discussed earlier. How many Americans would be unhappy if that child married someone from the opposing political party? And what we found is that journalists vastly overestimated this level of polarization. They believed that something like half of Americans
所以他们开始主导这些故事，作为党派关系有多糟糕的例子。Yana 在美国各地对数百名记者进行了研究。她问了我们之前讨论过的婚姻问题。有多少美国人会因为孩子与不同政党的人结婚而不高兴？我们发现记者大大高估了这种极化程度。他们认为大约有一半的美国人
would be quite profoundly polarized. When that is actually not the case, when we look over our sample, it was a tremendous kind of difference between what journalists suspected was the case and what actually was the case in our sample. Many journalists also have a love affair with social media, particularly ex, also known by its former name, Twitter. What do they see when they get on their feeds? The people who love to talk about politics. There's this fascinating work by scholar Shannon McGregor that shows the journalists are often turning to Twitter as a gauge of public opinion.
会非常深刻地极化。当事实并非如此时，当我们查看我们的样本时，记者怀疑的情况与我们样本中的实际情况之间存在巨大的差异。许多记者也对社交媒体有染，特别是 X，也就是以前的名字 Twitter。当他们进入信息流时，他们看到了什么？那些喜欢谈论政治的人。学者 Shannon McGregor 的一项迷人研究表明，记者经常转向推特作为衡量公众舆论的标尺。
Well, if the deeply involved are much more likely to express themselves on Twitter. And if journalists are looking to Twitter for stories for public opinion, they are certainly having a higher probability of landing on the opinions of the deeply involved and then elevating those perceptions to stories on polarization, of stories of discord, of stories of violence. There's a fact that many journalists themselves live and work in communities of deep involvement in politics, play a role in this as well.
好吧，如果深度参与者更有可能在推特上表达自己。如果记者在推特上寻找公众舆论的故事，他们肯定有更高的概率接触到深度参与者的观点，然后将这些看法提升为关于极化的故事、关于不和的故事、关于暴力的故事。许多记者自己生活和工作在深度参与政治的社区中，这也起到了作用。
I mean, I'm thinking of journalists certainly within the Washington Beltway. They're embedded in communities and neighborhoods where lots of their friends and neighbors are probably among the ranks of the deeply involved. I would think that it does. When I think of myself, for example, when I log on to Twitter, I'm in a network of people who are deeply involved in politics. And so often it's almost difficult for me to remember
我的意思是，我想到华盛顿特区内的记者。他们嵌入在社区和邻里中，他们的许多朋友和邻居可能都在深度参与者的行列中。我想这确实有影响。例如，当我想到我自己时，当我登录推特时，我处于一个深度参与政治的人的网络中。所以通常我几乎很难记住
that there are all these people in my own survey data for whom politics is actually much, much less important. And I imagine for journalists, it actually must be exacerbated. They're also in these kinds of networks. They're often in networks with other journalists. So essentially, there's constantly somebody there reinforcing your view of what is important and what politics looks like and what the world looks like. And so in that sense, it is a perspective of the world that is actually completely in
在我的调查数据中，有那么多人对他们来说政治实际上要重要得多。我想对于记者来说，这一定加剧了。他们也处于这种网络中。他们经常与其他记者处于网络中。所以本质上，总有人在那里强化你对什么是重要的、政治是什么样子以及世界是什么样子的看法。所以从这个意义上说，这是一种看待世界的视角，实际上与你周围看到的世界完全
line with the world you see around you. But the world you see around you may not necessarily be reflective of a large group of people. One of the most troubling things I took away from your work is how privilege might intersect with political involvement. So the person working three jobs to make ends meet, it's probably not the person who really cares that the president was up at night tweeting made up words. Many working parents, you know, they might be too exhausted with work and childcare to be up in arms about the latest brouhaha on Twitter.
一致。但你周围看到的世界可能并不一定反映了一大群人。我从你的工作中得到的最令人不安的事情之一是特权如何与政治参与交叉。所以那个为了维持生计而打三份工的人，可能不是那个真正关心总统晚上不睡觉发推文编造词汇的人。许多工作的父母，你知道，他们可能太累于工作和育儿，而无法对推特上的最新喧嚣感到愤怒。
So when we privilege the voices of the deeply involved, at some level, are we also privileging the voices of the privileged? I think there are two ways to look at it. On the one hand, I think there is a certain privilege to not following politics, where you sort of feel so comfortable about your state in the country that you don't necessarily care who wins. But I think there's another privilege and that is spending a lot of time following politics. I feel like I have a tremendous amount of privilege in my job that I can check in and
那么，当我们赋予那些深度参与政治的人更多话语权时，在某种程度上，我们是否也在赋予那些特权阶层更多话语权？我认为可以从两个方面来看。一方面，我认为不关注政治本身就是一种特权，因为你对国家现状感到足够舒适，以至于你并不一定在乎谁会获胜。但我觉得还有另一种特权，那就是花大量时间关注政治。我觉得我的工作给了我巨大的特权，我可以随时查看
see what's happening on the news, that I'm afforded the flexibility to do so, that I can follow a debate or that I can follow a congressional hearing, for example, if I so chose. But when I think about kind of the world of people who are working hourly jobs, who are single parents, who are basically living kind of paycheck to paycheck, politics may not be something they just have time for. Spending a lot of time figuring out the latest presidential tweet
新闻动态，我有这种灵活性，比如我可以选择关注一场辩论或一场国会听证会。但当我想到那些从事时薪工作、身为单亲父母、基本上靠薪水过活的人时，政治可能并不是他们有时间去关注的事情。花大量时间去研究总统最新的推文
is not necessarily going to be something that when they have downtime, they're going to be able that when they have down time, they're going to be able to do. They probably rather spend time with their kids or their families. So I think there is certainly a privilege to actually being able to spend the time on politics that I think a lot of people in this country just don't have. How do people who are deeply involved in politics affect our larger discourse?
并不一定是他们在闲暇时能够做到的事情。他们可能更愿意把时间花在孩子或家人身上。所以我认为，能够花时间关注政治确实是一种特权，而我认为这个国家的许多人根本没有这种特权。那些深度参与政治的人是如何影响我们更广泛的讨论的呢？
Our ability to find solutions and make compromises. That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. People who are deeply involved in politics have strong convictions. They talk about politics all the time because they are worried about the state of the country, the economy. They care. They believe that if they can only get other Americans to care as much as they do, we would all be better off.
我们寻找解决方案和达成妥协的能力。稍后回来。您正在收听的是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。深度参与政治的人有着坚定的信念。他们总是谈论政治，因为他们担心国家和经济的状况。他们在乎。他们相信，如果能让其他美国人也像他们一样在乎，我们大家都会过得更好。
Are they succeeding? University of Michigan political scientist Yana Kripnikov studies the deeply involved and how their outsized role in politics and media coverage shapes our understanding of partisanship in the United States. Yana, people who are deeply involved in politics want to engage people who are not involved because they want to affect change. They want others to see the importance of political issues and political causes.
他们成功了吗？密歇根大学政治学家亚娜·克里普尼科夫研究了这些深度参与者，以及他们在政治和媒体报道中的巨大作用如何塑造了我们对美国党派之争的理解。亚娜，那些深度参与政治的人想要吸引那些不参与的人，因为他们想推动变革。他们希望其他人看到政治议题和政治事业的重要性。
Are they effective at doing this? So I think the goals of the deeply involved are actually coming from a good place. If you are looking over the spectrum of politics and you see things happening in front of you that you think are horrifying and terrible and problematic, you want other people to know about this. You want other people to know that they should be anxious and they should be afraid and bad things could be coming. But I think there is this sense of deep involvement that may not necessarily translate to others. When others see somebody who is profoundly involved in
他们这样做有效吗？我认为深度参与者的目标其实是出于好意。如果你审视整个政治光谱，看到眼前发生的事情让你觉得可怕、糟糕且充满问题，你会希望其他人也知道这一点。你希望其他人知道他们应该感到焦虑和恐惧，坏事可能即将发生。但我认为这种深度参与感并不一定会转化为对他人的影响。当其他人看到一个深度参与
politics, it might send the message that to be at all engaged, that is how you should behave. That it's not enough to just kind of sporadically follow the news or to pay attention during elections, but you have to sort of live and breathe politics. And that's how you become somebody who is politically engaged or knows anything political. And I think that's tough for people. I think for people who may not necessarily have the time or the strong interest, believing that this is how political engagement works may be a kind of a tough example to swallow, which I think can undermine the effectiveness of those who
政治的人时，这可能会传达出一种信息：要参与政治，就必须像他们那样行事。仅仅偶尔关注新闻或在选举期间留意是不够的，你必须以政治为生。这就是你成为一个政治参与者或了解政治的人的方式。我认为这对人们来说很难。对于那些不一定有时间或强烈兴趣的人来说，相信这就是政治参与的方式可能是一个难以接受的例子，我认为这会削弱那些
are politically involved, encouraging others to become more engaged as well. There's a very interesting psychological theory that you're advancing here. In some ways, you're saying the deeply involved in some ways have become our role models of how it is to be involved in politics. When we look at the deeply involved, when we turn on cable news in the evenings and we hear them, when we turn on Twitter and we watch the debates raging on Twitter, we think this is how, if you're interested in politics, this is how you have to be involved in politics.
政治参与者鼓励他人也参与进来的效果。你在这里提出了一个非常有趣的心理学理论。在某种程度上，你是说深度参与者在某种程度上成为了我们参与政治的榜样。当我们观察这些深度参与者，当我们晚上打开有线电视新闻听到他们的声音，当我们打开推特看到上面激烈的辩论时，我们认为，如果你对政治感兴趣，你就必须以这种方式参与政治。
Then we ask ourselves the question, do I want to be that kind of person? What you're saying is for many people, the answer might be no. Yeah, a lot of times when we categorize ourselves, as research and psychology suggests, we compare ourselves to other people and we sort of say, am I like this person? Am I similar to this person? In what ways that I'm different?
然后我们问自己一个问题：我想成为那样的人吗？你的意思是，对许多人来说，答案可能是否定的。是的，很多时候，正如心理学研究表明的那样，当我们进行自我归类时，我们会将自己与他人进行比较，并会问：我像这个人吗？我与这个人相似吗？我在哪些方面与他不同？
And I think in some sense, when people compare themselves to the deeply involved, they're obviously going to see that they are quite different. Maybe they're going to think, I don't feel quite as strongly or, you know, I vote in these national elections, but I can't bring myself to vote in these local elections. I just don't know enough. And that contributes to our self-categorization as somebody who is ostensibly non-political, which is I think a descriptor I actually hear quite a lot from people.
我认为在某种意义上，当人们将自己与深度参与者进行比较时，他们显然会发现自己非常不同。也许他们会想，我没有那么强烈的感受，或者，你知道，我在全国性选举中投票，但我无法让自己在地方选举中投票。我了解得不够多。这导致我们将自己归类为表面上的“非政治人士”，我认为这是一个我经常从人们那里听到的描述。
I'm not political. And I think an interesting question there becomes, are you not political or are you not deeply involved? Are you actually entirely disengaged from politics or do you just not believe that you have any capacity to be part of politics because you don't think you can look like the people you see on your television screen? I'm wondering if there's another effect here, which is that if I'm a Democrat and I'm watching television and I'm seeing people who are deeply involved in politics, who are Republicans on television, it's reasonable almost for me to draw the impression that all Republicans must be like the Republicans that I see on television.
“我不关心政治。”我认为这里有一个有趣的问题：你是真的不关心政治，还是只是没有深度参与？你是完全脱离了政治，还是只是不相信自己有能力参与政治，因为你认为自己无法像电视上看到的那样？我想知道这里是否还有另一种效应，即如果我是一个民主党人，我在看电视时看到那些深度参与政治的人，而他们是共和党人，那么我几乎理所当然地会产生一种印象，即所有的共和党人一定都像我在电视上看到的那些共和党人一样。
In fact, some research I've recently done suggests that very point. Along with co-authors Samaric Clark, John Ryan, Jamie Druckerman, and Matt Levin Dusky, we actually asked people what they believe the most common member of the opposing party looks like. And then we actually measured what people from both parties look like. And what we found is that people imagined that those from the other party were constantly talking about politics and that they were very extreme. But in fact, that's not the case at all. The sort of most common member of a party, a person on a survey who says they're a Democrat or Republican, is somebody who doesn't talk about politics all that much and somebody who is not
事实上，我最近做的一些研究就指出了这一点。我和合著者萨马里克·克拉克、约翰·瑞安、杰米·德鲁克曼和马特·莱文·杜斯基一起，询问了人们认为对方党派中最常见的成员是什么样的。然后我们测量了双方党派成员的真实情况。我们发现，人们想象对方党派的人总是谈论政治，而且非常极端。但事实上，情况根本不是这样。一个党派中最常见的成员，即在调查中自称是民主党人或共和党人的人，其实是一个并不怎么谈论政治的人，也是一个
all that extreme. And so the difference between what the partisans actually look like and what people imagine the partisans actually look like was quite jarring. But it's not as jarring when you think about the partisans that you see on Twitter, the partisans that you see on television, the partisans you see in the news. People who are reasonable and dispassionate don't necessarily make for the best political news, especially if you want to illustrate polarization. And so when we see people who are quite angry, it forms our idea of what a partisan is and what somebody who is political actually looks like. When I look at the voter turnout in recent elections, the biggest party by far might not
并不那么极端的人。因此，党派人士的真实情况与人们想象的情况之间的差异非常惊人。但当你想到你在推特上、电视上、新闻中看到的那些党派人士时，这种差异就不那么令人震惊了。理智且冷静的人并不一定能制造出最好的政治新闻，尤其是如果你想展示两极分化的话。所以，当我们看到那些非常愤怒的人时，它就形成了我们对“党派人士”以及“政治人士”真实模样的认知。当我观察最近选举的投票率时，最大的党派可能根本不是
be the Republican Party or the Democratic Party. It might be the party of what you might call, please leave me out of it. Among all Americans of voting age, about two and five, about 40% typically don't vote. Now, this has been true for a long time. It probably precedes the growth and popularity of social media. But is there a connection between the story you tell about this new fault line and people who are completely disengaging from politics? Well, this is a worry of mine when I think about deep involvement. If we sort of communicate to people that
共和党或民主党。它可能是你所说的“请别把我算在内”党。在所有达到投票年龄的美国人中，大约五分之二，即约40%的人通常不投票。这种情况已经持续很长时间了。它可能早于社交媒体的兴起和普及。但是，你所讲述的关于这条新断层线的故事与那些完全脱离政治的人之间是否存在联系？嗯，当我想到深度参与时，这确实是我担心的问题。如果我们向人们传达这样一种信息，即
politics is about being angry, that politics is about essentially, and I don't just mean being angry about the events we see around us, because I think people should in a lot of cases be very angry about the political events we see around us, but essentially the politics is constantly about fighting and spending a lot of time expressing this, it might suggest to people that they don't have what it takes to be a part of politics. So when we think about people essentially disengaging, part of it might be people sort of saying, I don't necessarily want to be part of this. necessarily want to be part of this. I don't want to be like partisans. I don't necessarily want to be in a group
政治就是关于愤怒，政治本质上就是——我指的不仅仅是对我们周围发生的事件感到愤怒，因为我认为在很多情况下人们确实应该对我们看到的政治事件感到非常愤怒——但本质上，政治总是关于争吵和花费大量时间表达这种愤怒，这可能会让人们觉得他们没有能力参与政治。所以当我们想到人们本质上脱离政治时，部分原因可能是人们在说：我并不一定想参与其中。我不想像那些党派人士一样。我并不一定想和
with these people I see around me. Yano's research finds that these people are not just reluctant to get involved in politics. They feel less confident in their ability to do so. If you think that you're non-political because you're different from those you see in the news, it might suggest to you that your voice is just not as worthwhile.
我周围看到的这些人待在一个群体里。亚娜的研究发现，这些人不仅不愿参与政治，而且对自己的参与能力也缺乏信心。如果你认为自己是非政治人士，因为你与新闻中看到的人不同，这可能会让你觉得你的声音没那么有价值。
And you might actually even start to believe that you don't know enough to be part of the political world. You don't know enough to be part of the political world. You don't know enough to actually participate, which I think could lead to people kind of exiting out of the process. Yeah. You cite a story that was once published in the New York Times about a woman who decided to set out a recent election. She decided not to vote.
你甚至可能开始相信自己了解得不够多，无法成为政治世界的一部分。你了解得不够多，无法参与其中，我认为这可能导致人们退出这个过程。是的。你引用了《纽约时报》曾经发表的一篇关于一位女性决定不参加最近一次选举的故事。她决定不去投票。
And she had, I believe, friends or siblings who had very different feelings about what happened. Tell me that story. So this story was quite interesting to us, and it was in the back of our minds as we were working through our theoretic work. And it's this woman who talked about deciding that she wasn't going to turn out to vote. And she had these two close friends who basically started texting her repeatedly, almost trying to shame her into turning out and voting. And in the end, she didn't vote, so it was not effective.
我相信她有朋友或兄弟姐妹对发生的事情有非常不同的感受。给我讲讲那个故事。这个故事对我们来说非常有趣，在我们进行理论研究时，它一直萦绕在我们的脑海中。这是一个关于一位女性的故事，她谈到自己决定不去投票。她有两个亲密的朋友，基本上开始反复给她发短信，几乎是在试图羞辱她，强迫她去投票。最后，她还是没有投票，所以这种做法并不奏效。
But it was effective in her essentially stopping being friends with these people, people who she reports actually having been friends with for a long time, I think. And the other thing that she reports that was especially kind of sad in some ways is that she actually never really engaged with politics again. It was such a poor experience for her that it led her to exit out of politics entirely. And you can see this story, I think, from both sides. I think the people who were trying to convince her to vote, genuinely wanted to see this person engaged in politics. They genuinely believe politics is important. They genuinely want people to vote.
但它确实奏效的一点是，她基本上不再与这些人做朋友了，据她说，这些人其实是她认识很久的朋友。她报告的另一件在某些方面特别令人难过的事情是，她实际上再也没有真正参与过政治。那次糟糕的经历导致她完全退出了政治。我认为你可以从双方的角度来看待这个故事。我认为那些试图说服她投票的人，是真心希望看到这个人参与政治。他们真心相信政治很重要。他们真心希望人们去投票。
But what happened was an entirely opposing reaction, which sort of speaks to this idea of how we communicate the importance of politics to others. So there's something deeply ironic here, because as you said, the deeply involved are deeply involved because they care so much. They have deep ideals very often about what's right and what's wrong and how to make things better. But paradoxically, in terms of actual effectiveness, they might not actually be getting their way, not just because they're driving disengagement among some people, but also because, as you point out, the deeply engaged are also the
但结果却完全相反，这说明了我们如何向他人传达政治的重要性。所以这里面有一种深刻的讽刺，因为正如你所说，深度参与者之所以深度参与，是因为他们非常在乎。他们往往对什么是对、什么是错以及如何让事情变得更好有着深刻的理想。但矛盾的是，就实际效果而言，他们可能并没有达到目的，这不仅是因为他们在某些人中引发了疏离感，还因为正如你指出的，深度参与者也是
ones who are least interested in compromise. So compromise is a dirty word when it comes to the people who are the most deeply engaged in politics. What does it mean for a democracy, Yana, when the people who are in the fray, who stay in the fray, are the ones who say any compromise with the other side is effectively betrayal and treason, and we are driving out the people who might in some ways be more amenable to compromise.
最不愿妥协的人。所以对于那些最深度参与政治的人来说，“妥协”是一个肮脏的词。亚娜，当那些身处纷争之中、并坚持留在纷争之中的人，声称与对方的任何妥协实际上都是背叛和叛国，并且我们正在驱逐那些在某些方面可能更愿意妥协的人时，这对民主意味着什么？
Oh, I think there are sort of two ways to look at this. I think one, as more and more people who are less involved are driven out of politics, we see more of these people who are less involved are driven out of politics. We see more of these people who are deeply involved, basically engaging with each other, fully kind of convinced of their own level of interest, basically just reinforcing each other's views. And then you have another half of your electorate
哦，我认为可以从两个方面来看。我认为第一，随着越来越多参与度较低的人被挤出政治，我们看到更多这些深度参与的人，基本上是在相互交流，完全沉浸在自己的兴趣水平中，基本上只是在强化彼此的观点。然后你还有另一半选民
who's becoming less and less and less engaged. What are we losing in this case? Are we losing certain voices that could essentially be represented? Are we changing who is being represented? Are we essentially altering the extent to which government can be responsible? I think these are all things that we should kind of think about when we think about what it means when we give the deeply involved so much voice. One of the most surprising things about your thesis as I was reading your work is how many
变得越来越不参与。在这种情况下我们失去了什么？我们是否失去了一些本可以得到代表的声音？我们是否改变了谁在被代表？我们是否在本质上改变了政府能够负责任的程度？我认为当我们思考赋予深度参与者如此多的话语权意味着什么时，这些都是我们应该考虑的问题。在阅读你的作品时，最让我惊讶的事情之一是，有多少
Americans think of people who belong to their own political party who are deeply involved. Obviously, many Americans dislike partisans on the other side who are deeply involved, but how do people think about people on their own side who are deeply involved? Certainly, people like those on their own side who are deeply involved a lot better than they like those on the other side who are deeply involved a lot better than they like those on the other side who are deeply involved. But there's also some sense that people aren't necessarily all that excited about people who are deeply involved on their own side as well. People who are not deeply involved don't exactly love people who tweet about politics even from their own side.
美国人看待自己所属政党中深度参与的人。显然，许多美国人不喜欢对方阵营中深度参与的党派人士，但人们是如何看待自己阵营中深度参与的人的呢？当然，人们确实比喜欢对方阵营中深度参与的人更喜欢自己阵营中深度参与的人。但也有一些感觉，人们并不一定对本阵营中深度参与的人感到那么兴奋。那些不深度参与的人并不完全喜欢那些即使是来自自己阵营、整天在推特上谈论政治的人。
So certainly, certainly, I think if we kind of truth-sarmed people, they would say, well, if you're gonna tweet about politics, at least do it from my side. But they don't necessarily love that either. I sense in some ways that there is an irony in your work, Yana, because you've mentioned in a couple of different ways that you yourself might belong to the ranks of the people who are deeply involved. You talked about it briefly in the context of many of your friends on social media being deeply involved. You have a critique of the deeply involved and sort of the
所以当然，当然，我认为如果我们对人们进行测谎，他们会说，好吧，如果你一定要在推特上谈论政治，至少站在我这边。但他们也不一定喜欢那样。我感觉到你的作品中在某种程度上有一种讽刺，亚娜，因为你以几种不同的方式提到，你自己可能也属于深度参与者行列。你在谈到社交媒体上的许多朋友都是深度参与者时简要提到了这一点。你对深度参与者以及某种程度上
effect they're having on politics. At some level, are you also critiquing your own life and your own approach to politics? By my definition, I probably am quite deeply involved. And in fact, I do, in fact, check the news in the morning when I wake up. In that sense, I do think that I am critiquing my own life in a way. I've found a number of points actually having to remind myself, there are people out there who are much more concerned about where their next paycheck is going to come from, whether they have time to spend with their kids than with the latest thing the president has tweeted. And I think working on this has been a helpful reminder of this constant voice that I should hear in my head of, this is not real life.
他们对政治产生的影响持批评态度。在某种程度上，你是否也在批评你自己的生活和你自己的政治方式？按照我的定义，我可能确实是深度参与者。事实上，我确实会在早上醒来时查看新闻。从这个意义上说，我确实认为我是在以某种方式批评我自己的生活。我发现实际上有几次不得不提醒自己，外面有很多人比关注总统最新的推文更关心下一张薪水支票从哪里来，以及是否有时间陪伴孩子。我认为研究这个课题是一个有益的提醒，提醒我脑海中应该有这样一个持续的声音：这不是真实的生活。
Yana Kriplnikov is a political scientist at the University of Michigan. Her book, written with her fellow political scientist, John Barry Ryan, is called The Other Divide, Polarization and Disengagement in American Politics. Yana, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Quarrell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brainins Executive Editor. Next week, we wrap up our US 2.0 series with a dive into history. We'll hear a fresh perspective on the man who navigated the United States through a perilous moment in its history, Abraham Lincoln.
亚娜·克里普尼科夫是密歇根大学的政治学家。她与同事、政治学家约翰·巴里·瑞安合著的书名为《另一种分歧：美国政治中的两极分化与疏离》。亚娜，感谢你今天参加《Hidden Brain》节目。谢谢你的邀请。《Hidden Brain》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯蒂安·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行编辑。下周，我们将通过深入研究历史来结束我们的“美国 2.0”系列节目。我们将听到关于那位带领美国度过历史危急时刻的人——亚伯拉罕·林肯——的全新视角。
We talk with NPR Stephen Ski about the nation's 16th president and the lessons his leadership still holds for us. If you've missed any of the episodes in our Us 2.0 series, you can find them in the podcast feed or on our website, hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantan. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们与 NPR 的斯蒂芬·斯基谈论了这位国家第 16 任总统，以及他的领导力对我们今天依然具有的启示。如果您错过了“美国 2.0”系列中的任何一集，您可以在播客订阅源或我们的网站 hiddenbrain.org 上找到它们。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。